So here we go. Dude, my opener, when we were in a,
I don't even know where the we were. How about that? How about where I,
how about, I never know where the I am, dude. Um,
so I was in, um, somewhere, got to the airport.
Oh, this was in Cincinnati, which by the way, the airport,
Cincinnati is in Kentucky. Right? Hey,
go yourself, man. Put it in the actual city. So confusing when you land.
You're like I'm in Kentucky. Oh, I flew to the wrong place,
I guess the right next to each other. But anyway, uh,
look at this Cincinnati Northern and Northern Kentucky international airport
pick one. So I get to,
I get to the place, uh,
to fly back out to beautiful sunny Los Angeles, California.
That's been raining so much.
And I notice in the airport on the carpet of the
airport with planes on it, carpets and airports. We have planes on it.
Like they think that that's like a cute thing. Like get out, get outta here,
dude. This is not a boat tickets to make it, make it drab is.
It's an airport. Don't try to cheer me up in an airport. I'm in an airport.
I want to be. Let me be,
let me feel like there's people with like diseases around because it should
be, uh, that fluorescent lighting white walls.
And don't make it cute because it make it drab as.
So I get to the airport and um,
I noticed I looked down and there's straight up tracked
all over the floor of the airport now. Yeah. Welcome to Cincinnati.
However, there's tracked all over the air, all over the,
all over. And I'm like, Ooh.
And as I'm looking at this track,
I noticed my opener checking the bottom of his shoes,
which only means one thing he's stepped in it.
And what's only means another thing. I'm thrilled. Okay.
So as he's looking, I noticed, I was like, Oh, it's, I'm laughing.
And he's like, did I, what the? He's mumbling as you do anyone who steps in.
The one thing that you're doing is looking at the bottom of your shoe.
And the other thing you're doing is not saying words.
You're literally just going this, what the? Right?
So he's doing that. Okay. Now I'm not laughing yet. No.
The reason why I'm not laughing yet is because it's
Oh, dark 30. It's way too early.
The flight was so early because I needed to get on the one that
connected to that. Didn't connect to Los Angeles. For some reason,
if you want a straight shot in the Midwest to lax,
you've got to wake up at Oh, dark 30.
All right.
If you don't wake up at Oh, dark 30. Guess what?
Connecting like a plebeian. Okay. Now I don't want to connect.
You can get a noon flight. Congratulations. But guess what?
You've got to connect in Dallas. You got to connect it in Atlanta.
Now that's what we call out of the way.
I've decided to only connect now. Cause these early flights, man.
So you got to fly out. When you, if you don't connect,
you want a straight shot to lax. You gotta, you gotta fly out.
Literally the.
Same time that they killed bin Ladin, whatever time that was. You gotta,
you gotta do it so early there's with night vision goggles on
at the airport. It sucked.
Yeah.
So he's checking his going. I'm on something.
I'm not coming home with all the bags and I'm like, it. I don't give a.
I'm just going to keep moving because I can't laugh yet because it's old,
dark 30. Okay. It's the time that they killed bin Laden.
So
we get to the thing now I got clear.
I got clear my opener. He doesn't have clear.
You hear me now granted Cincinnati airport.
I don't even know if they have clear and I don't remember, but if they do it,
doesn't matter because nobody's going to the Cincinnati airport because you
don't need to use the clear.
You don't even do it to get a pre you just get there. And it's like, yeah,
come on in. You're the only guy. So I,
I, we get through the TSA and he's like.
He's a good dude. I step in.
And I'm like, Oh bro, you did, man.
I noticed it was in the airport.
And he's like, what?
And I'm like, w w it was actually inside.
And I noticed while it was happening, I, I, it was on the floor. I,
I noticed it while you were already thought, saw it and saw it on the bottom.
Yeah.
And he says, are you kidding me?
And I was like, uh, nah, it was inside. He was inside.
Inside the, inside the airport. And I'm like, yeah. He's like,
are you kidding me, dude? It's 4:00 AM.
And I, and he, he, by the way, he had on like,
kind of like new Jordans that were like kind. So we, I was like, actually like,
dude, like they're kind of dope. Like I should maybe get them.
So he had on Jordans that I liked. And by the way,
the only reason why he gets Jordans is because I've convinced him that they're
cool. And now he's like doing it because he's like, Oh yeah,
this is the shoes to get. He freely admits it because like, I don't know,
fashion. I got to get the cruiser. So he's got the nice Jordans.
I stepped in the and then it past TSA was like, so I was like, it.
I can't, it smells like, man. And I was like, he's like,
how the does Cincinnati have in the airport? He's like, this place.
So we're getting a lot. We're getting in line at Starbucks, which is like,
the airport always has the one. They always have the sucker Starbucks.
They always have the sucker Starbucks.
And then they have the actual Starbucks that you should go to.
Cause no one's going now like a up because it's so dark 30. I get past the TSA.
I see the sucker Starbucks. Now,
the reason why it's the sucker Starbucks is because the line is longer than the
line in Russia for bread in 1980. You know?
So I'm in this long line waiting and I'm not
even thinking I'm just on autopilot. And he's like, dude,
I got to go wash your off the bottom of my shoes. Like, no, dude,
I pay you to hang out with me. Stay in this long line with me. He was like,
dude, I, you know what? You gotta be crazy.
And he disobeyed me and I respect him for that. You understand me?
I respect him for that because he's passionate about getting this
off the bottom of his shoes.
So I start laughing hard and he starts walking to the bathroom.
Now the bathroom is so far away. Now he passed, he passed,
he passed passes, almost had a stroke right there.
He passes the non sucker Starbucks where there's nobody.
There you go. There.
It's like a open field because everyone's at the sucker Starbucks.
Cause it's the first Starbucks. Now I'm waiting in line.
I don't know that there's Starbucks over there. I'm going to thinking about it.
But he watches the. I get through the whole line.
It's like you walk through the carwash because it took so long.
I ordered the iced Americanos because that's what you get at. Oh,
dark 30. And we,
and I guess what I do, I splurge, man.
I'm trying to work on my trunk. I'm trying to shred down my trunk,
but not at Oh, dark 30 dude. You got to take some liberties, man. Guess what?
I got a cinnamon bagel with two cream, cheeses got two of them, one for me,
one for my opener. And I mean because he's got and I, because he's at stage,
he's great on stage, but he's actually technically.
So I get them that and he, I get, they say,
you know, cinnamon bagel, they got my ice Americano. I'm eating the.
He comes back and he sits down in a half and he's like, dude,
it's like, I can't get it off, man. I'm a, no matter what I do, it's like,
I have under my nose, man. It's like a Kia. Stop smelling it.
And I'm laughing, crying is so much funnier when you're tired.
is so much funnier. And I'll tell you this much,
I'm better on stage when I'm tired because I'm loosey goosey all about having
that silly goose moment. Dude,
you think I'm sitting down for a silly goose time and that's it when I'm tired
and I got bags,
my eyes, dude,
it is silly goose exponential.
It is silly goose with that two on the side of,
on the upper side of it because we're doing, whatever that math is,
math. You know, anything but basic math you got in into other, man.
But there's a whole nother story. That's another podcast another day.
So he is so and I get my cinnamon bagel,
by the way,
for some reason only one of the cinnamon bagels was ready and I'm eating this.
And he was like, where's the mine dude. And I'm like, I don't know, man,
you got to ask for it. I guess they didn't bring it out. And he's like.
So it gets up and does it. And he eats it dude.
And he's miserable eating it, but it was so good that he says,
he goes like this. He says,
This is such a, you had to be there moment. I don't give a.
I'm still telling you. Cause that's how we get here. Do it.
I'm disrespected on you mother. My whole, I want my holster.
That's my dream dude, to get my whole standup to just be a,
you had to be there moment. I want my whole audience in the audience to be like,
I guess that's my goal, dude. They're like it doesn't I,
it seems like you had to be there. I want no one laughing,
just straight up audience members being like, sounds like you.
The booth.
So he gets the cinema and he's all huffing and puffing, eating the thing,
smelling under his nose, right?
Like he's got a stash and Andy and he's eating this bagel and he's
just.
Man, it's like a donut.
And we just didn't
stop laughing for 11
minutes.
It hit us good dude.
The Cupid of funniness just took that at bow and arrow and
rocket it through the back right through our hearts. And we just started crying,
laughing immediately because we were eating a doughnut dude.
these bagels that get creative. That is a donut bro.
Cinnamon raisin bagels. Get a donut.
I realized I up. I should've just got the donut dude.
Cinnamon raisin bagel. Hey,
don't call that a bagel. You fat.
That's a donut. Oh, it was,
you know what? It was better than a donut dude.
If have you had a cinnamon raisin bagel with two
cream cheeses, Peggy at,
at dark 30.
Hey, that's it.
My hands are tied now. That's it dude. You know what? Actually,
I'll tell you. I'll tell you this right now. If you've had a cinnamon bagel,
uh, at, at, at, Oh, dark 30 with two cream cheeses.
that dude. That's what you're that's what's going on in your head right there.
When you take that bite and you go like this and this is the bike.
When you go like this and you're going like this and you go like this, huh?
Can you spread it?
Dude.
Spreading the bagel, leading the bagel, putting under Oh wow.
They toasted a nice, just right. Not too much.
[inaudible].
And then you're just,
you're good for the rest of the day, my babies.
Or if you have on the bottom of your Jordans that balanced it, the out,
it that's about bed. So life's about, it's about balance. Life's about balance.
You step in some, you get a cinnamon bagel, you know,
the most Italian thing to say, Hey, you know, you step in some. You gotta,
you know, you love you. You balance it out with a cinnamon bagel, right? Yeah.
Hey, you're a doughnut, but you know,